what's up reject nation of Greg Alba I'm
John Humphrey we're gonna watch the
mandalorian chapter two I'm excited to
check this out the first episode was a
really cool experience getting a lot of
things established own whatnot and
ending that raise a lot of questions of
like what's this baby you want a
character so see how things unfold so
before we go into this guy's I wanted to
say thank you to Eric over at nerd
cronic for editing at this video for us
he's cutting it down so we could put
this up on YouTube he has done work for
people like Eamon snow Hakkasan movie
trivia Schmo down he has his own podcast
as well he can only put up reaction
highlights like everyone else who has a
reaction up here on YouTube so he's
cutting them down for us and we actually
do full-length reactions stream along
where he could sync up with a timecode
over at our patreon page that's for the
full-length uncut reaction for the
mandalorian will be where you could sync
up when watch along with us and there's
other shows that we'd cover as well
those are agents of shield stranger
things season 3 Gotham honey Hill house
season 1 Cobra Kai season 2 and there
are other shows we have stream alongs
and but also we do reaction highlights
for them as well so you don't have to
worry about syncing up and those shows
are supernatural Hunter hunter code
geass Death Note my hero academia movie
included Full Metal Alchemist
Brotherhood attack on Titan and one
punch man going over our patreon page to
check out all those shows and if you
want to stream along with us to watch
the mandalorian over there all right
let's mean to this
[Applause]
nice Wow sci-fi healing techniques no
more needles and thread take his first
steps
[Music]
let's go smack OH
Oh thing just gotta make me smile a
whole show yeah it's gonna be all about
little moments that stain your
intergalactic Krewe looters you will
have seen those characters in a new hope
remember that oh oh nothing have so much
joy watching him to kill thanos gun
whoa
[Music]
well Jesus it's cool shot yeah well no I
love them
no I shouldn't really yeah I love this
guy oh no how ya like a Mandalorian
armor right there
yeah oh no no my man Oh is he taking it
off
Oh time to take off his helmet like Iron
Man yeah
should just CGI'd it hmm would have been
just as appealing that's right
I got someone you want to
[Music]
just go to Star Wars Ralph's yes but 16
bears
hey these it's cool if they interview
real characters this time yeah freaking
real that looks
no they're ten that cut to the baby I
just think of more things okay
yeah perfect lens flares it's just like
giant creature about them
[Music]
oh what a shot crazy shot yeah oh damn
oh no not a good call dude love the way
they stages yeah oh baby Otis gotta do
something yes I knew it
whoa oh that is beautiful
yeah that's cool please don't tear the
animal apartment oh oh sweet exact right
stabbing place
this scene was inspired by fantastic
beasts and where to find them exactly
there's gonna be a crossover eventually
on the timeline cinco mandos like we can
make a lot of lane together a partner's
guide
[Laughter]
hey come on show up right the right time
and oh yeah Mandalorians man to erase
this word I don't know people have been
using it as shorthand and reviews and
stuff would be unfortunate if it was
[Music]
[Laughter]
Jesus
[Music]
he's gonna learn to believe in something
bigger than himself he's gonna learn
about the horse hmm they're building the
Iron Man suit come out in a big old
Clinton has a bummer if this is a Marvel
Netflix show we could have spent like 10
episodes here I know you could have
spent the whole season here
we missed the steam room and OH was
showering with his arm up with his head
down and a hand against the wall yes you
have hmm that's another shirt right
there yeah I have spoken oh yeah get
that Nick Nolte t-shirt going come on
Rocky another one hand push it got it in
you
and so man no.1 on his way hunting
bounties throughout the galaxy
something's gonna shoot the ship sleep
it off yeah give that kids maybe shoulda
brought frogs right and we should be
Dixon put the Yoda and the thumbnail yes
[Music]
[Laughter]
that's cool that's cool so I didn't
recall this from the last episode what
happened we didn't give the reaction
they wanted as I recall it we weren't
really all that shocked about baby Yoda
and apparently that's just a big deal
because yeah we felt like victory like a
big deal we were confused I think the
show kind of wants you to be confused
should we have been like I don't know I
feel like we weren't like oh yeah it's
just a baby Yoda okay but like well I
hope that doesn't sway people from
stopping to watch or reviewing thoughts
on this you understand with a pilot
episode specifically that day of other
things that were actually going on in
life that I will not get into but that
day specifically and also it's the pilot
there's a lot that I'm like okay I want
to make sure I'm absorbing all the
information I'm like also hyper focus
I'm not as just settled into the
experience as I'm also trying to gather
everything and then when baby Yoda
showed up I was like what when I was
like huh yeah I mean we were confused in
questioning what was going on we talked
about it either way I love this episode
the first one I really liked and I knew
that that one was a lot of setup putting
us into the tone in the world and the
mood and I had a feel and I said it that
this next episode would probably bring
out more of the emotional stakes that
are going on here yeah I really got the
feels for that this relationship that he
has with this baby Yoda character you
know seeing more of
the emotional side to mando as Walters
column for now I like this one a lot
where he's struggling the whole time
it's just it's not a walk in the park
for this guy cuz the first episode you
establish how badass he is how lethal he
is how he can get [ __ ] not and then in
this episode he encounters those trend
Oh Sean's in a Collider release and
image I was like on Entertainment Weekly
they showed a first look of that moment
didn't mean that fight like even though
he handled it it would get feel a little
more that struggle but then when he's
trying to recover the sandcrawler from
the Jawas that moment was great because
you're like oh he's gonna handle it and
he's struggling the whole time to get up
there but then they get one up on him he
gets knocked out then he has to go
recover that egg and encounter the Rhino
he's just getting all the time it's cool
watching him struggling I like hearing
when he's getting like flustered and
frustrated and trying to communicate
with it all that it made me fall in love
with the mando character like I've
always drawn him in the first episode
this is flesh this amount and makes him
feel more human and it's cool that we're
able to get this full-on performance
even though you can't see his face I
felt more of the lived-in portrayal from
Pedro Pascal and everything he's doing
from voice body language it's just it's
like as opposed to just being cool
soldier he knows something as little as
when he's talking with the Java's and
negotiating and the way he has like his
leg up here and just sitting on the
floor who than him talking in there it
just feels like a human being and I'd
really love that and of course with the
baby Yoda character you know we were
talking about it's probably he's the
force at some point right he's gonna use
the force at some point and that of
course just adds a layer of mystery I
don't want to think too far down the
line in terms of how does this factor
into the rest of the lineage with the
Star Wars Canon cuz you know it's like
we've got in force awakened last Jedi
now a game Rises kinda Walker no this
has been brought up and this is after
Return of the Jedi but who is this
character exactly this this species is
it from Yoda will this factor into the
bigger picture perhaps um I am more
concerned about the immediacy of it and
I do kind of just like this action hero
storyline main badass loners character
action hero has to take care of a child
or a baby you know we've seen that a
bunch of times but now we're seeing the
Star Wars space western version of that
which i think is really neat which is
another kind of well-worn you know I
think they're doing a nice job of
transcribing all these Western tropes
into this world
it lends itself really well to it yeah
the biggest thing aside from all the
things you mentioned in this episode
that I appreciate it was just the
emphasis on visual storytelling body
language because there's so little
dialog in both of these after that even
this episode is less dialogue I think
than the last one it doesn't have any
trouble for me you know really
communicating its mood and the scope and
the direction the story is going and
yeah there's still a good amount of
mystery the mandalorian is a mysterious
character but I don't think that's a bad
thing necessarily and yeah this just
gets me excited to visit more and
explore more of this world the only
thing I don't want is just yeah for this
to start going at a Star Wars stuff
we're gonna start explaining stuff about
the original films hahaha because I
think this is doing a really nice job of
being a contained and separate story and
so yeah that was my only worry last time
maybe that hampered my reaction to
little Yoda cuz I was like are they
gonna you know really start doing
fanservice and that's kind of what I
don't want but well I mean I know from
the movies is it was that it's like yeah
Yoda died in Return of the Jedi I didn't
assume that was Yoda but yeah
immediately I wasn't fully aware that
not even the hardest hardcore the Star
Wars fans the ones who have like read
all the books watching shows don't
really know much about the species of
Yoda that has really big so I didn't
really know that yeah I mean you know
but of course the whole thing is
supposed to make you go yeah my hope is
that they can use that for both of us
basically yeah and I think they have to
I have queued up the Clone Wars I'm
gonna I'm gonna start watching the the
animated shows like a ma'am and that
zone now where I just want to get as
much absorbance and then eventually go
on to the video games it's raising this
mystery question because he has a
mission yeah as a client this is the
asset he has obtained the asset and now
he needs to deliver it back but of
course it's raising a lot of
questionable morality stuff for him like
I remember in the first episode there
was that flashback moment that you see
briefly he might have been adopted
himself Oh in some way yeah as his
village being destroyed and all that
yeah yeah and then then he grows up and
then the Mandalorian culture so maybe
that is playing out like I thought that
was very specific on why they tease that
emotional core whoo
for him that would eventually lead to
him making this decision he said that it
was fifty years old the the IG Droid
said that other species age different
mando repeats back here that he thinks
it's just a baby might be 50 years old
we don't know for sure yet
Yoda like a thousand years old or
something okay like there's like a
ridiculous age yeah yeah you just spend
a long time as a baby and maybe that's
why this species isn't very abundant but
it does raise the question why does an
AHA suck why does he want this baby Yoda
what is this doctor wanted right and I
got the impression Soph of wardro from
auvergne Hertzog was wearing the fact
that he had stormtroopers with him he
was a part of a line with the Empire oh
yeah I don't know what value they are
aware of how they knew about this baby
Yoda character either way like the fact
that this baby Yoda can already use the
force even and I like the Nugget that it
takes the wind out of baby and yeah that
was that was a nice moment and I thought
I just think the way they staged the
sequences is really well done like the
action moments are all staged in a
brilliant way like you've seen these
kind of fights before the way they do it
is just so close I like watching a fight
scene especially the one with mando
versus the Rhino oh yeah where he's
trying to figure out how to take this
thing down or whatever he like when he
does the what the hell do I call real a
the wire zips on to him and he's like
starting to like oh yeah he does it yeah
that's probably not a good idea but I
get where you're going for you yeah yeah
and I love and it harkens back to old
Star Wars and arrogance back to what I
think really sells a lot of futuristic
sci-fi stuff is is so dirty and it's so
like that whole scene is covered in mud
you know and the physical aspects versus
the CG it brings it together in a really
nice kind of lived in sort of way there
were moments early on in the episode
with some of the music actually was
making me flash to a little bit more the
harrowing sci-fi films of the past
something like Blade Runner you know
this is also giving me a little bit more
than just the plotline is children of
men which Clive owns on an action hero
taking care of a baby but it's kind of
like this might be the last of the Yoda
species no he just happens to stumble
upon this and has to take care of it and
deliver it somewhere there's some vibes
that I'm getting from that you know a
little bit of Logan meets children a
minute yeah yeah when I can imagine that
perhaps through this experience
especially in this episode when he gets
back to the clients I have a feeling
there's gonna be some kind of conflict
because you know they're gonna probably
want to cut him up or do something
sinister study at mando is gonna have to
step up and not let that happen
yeah he's not he's not also a chance out
to Nick Nolte's character something
queal I've not a spell his name - I
don't know I'm not sure how to pronounce
it I think he's a great character and I
have spoken will definitely be a major
patron quote oh I'm pretty sure I
haven't seen any memes online weapons
are my part of my religion bits are far
but I can rely don't know that's from
another like that was in rebels or
something but that that is a great luck
yeah like I want that shirt right now I
just want like a it's like a shadowed
mysterious picture of the mando which is
face and then this weapons are part of
our religion which I don't think is very
PC but yeah in the right context yeah in
in real life I would argue that's not a
good sentiment no pretty terrible last
thing I'll say is like with a job was I
thought was cool too is I thought there
are real real characters you know you
know we don't know what they were saying
they got some moments with a little bit
of subtitles sure but it was cool to
kind of explore a little bit more of who
they are even with the egg you know like
I don't exactly know but it's so
delicious yeah yeah delicacy maybe
that's what it is but just getting
acquainted with that yeah I I just think
it's a really nice touch I love this
this feels like a very lived in show
yeah the first one I really liked and I
was like I definitely want to keep
watching and this quickly got me on
board with I love this show yeah well I
think that's interesting too that the
length is not like a full hour-long show
or a 42 minutes show and it didn't feel
too short or too long this episode me
not only like a half hour and change so
I also appreciate that like with all
these budgetary concerns and stuff like
that it seems like they're playing this
in a smart
sort of slightly different structural
way did you see like with every episode
they're gonna tell it whatever length it
needs to be whatever whatever's required
for this story of this episode to
properly be told is doesn't see what
they're too bogged down by runtime well
what if they got effects to do and you
know stuff sure there's there's I
imagine the longer your script the more
expensive your episode yes absolutely
but still you know it's like I feel like
with streaming shows a specialist like
we cable we're kind of designed for
hour-long dramas absolutely
I think what's streaming to we usually
expect like the 50 to 60 minute mark for
most of these episodes and the first one
was like 40-something minutes this is 30
something then it's this one
specifically had a really cool pulse
about it it wasn't like oh this is a
much faster show now but there was a
rhythm that was quickly established
early on so she's since we did all the
setting up and a much slower build in
the first episode now we can pick up the
pace I really love the pacing to this
excited to see how things unfold man
yeah this is really is the I this was
great like I was into this completely
from beginning and I was able to just
set that itself back in so hell yeah all
right guys well thank you for being here
you can check out our full-length
reaction over our patreon page you guys
can subscribe to the real rejects click
on notification about get notified
whenever we got a new YouTube video up
including the next Mandalorian reaction
we'll catch you guys soon thanks again
to Eric over at Newark Rhonda for
putting this together